alors soyez là où la bienvenue à votre
temps canada du 15 janvier 2017
on va vous apprendre aujourd'hui à
comment bien glisser sur les routes
canadiennes hiver à donner des leçons
autour de la table ont fait le tour il
ya beaucoup de monde cette semaine comme
d'habitude lundi belles bonjour aura dit
bonjour et bonne année bonne année c'est
notre webmestre du côté francophone il
ya anne marie vont du secteur ou du du
département espace autochtones du canada
qui est avec nous bonne année ancien
collègue de radio canada international
qui cultivent les via encore aujourd'hui
avec bien siens d'ailleurs on aura
aujourd'hui deux nouveaux entrevue
encore récente que vous nous avez laissé
avant de partir comme ça et puis les
eaux gimeno de la section espagnole de
radio canada international de webmestres
chef bonjour c'est bien de venir ici est
toujours un poste plus haut ça ya des
promotions sont offerts vous avez
l'option de lever votre siège et un
petit
voilà c'est bien moi je ne descends
c'est mieux comme ça
écoutez aujourd'hui quand même assez
sérieux on va débattre ensemble des
dangers d'abord des accidents ici aucun
avant l'hiver parce qu'il faut changer
absolument de conduite faut pas aller
trouver de ça c'est la leçon de base
j'aime faire le tour de la terre bien
sûr on parle pas seulement des routes
pour les conducteurs mais les routes
pour les gens qui prennent le métro
y'a pas l'hiver dans le métro mis à
l'hiver en surface au niveau des autobus
mme rady est ce que vous prenez
l'autobus sommes en rien le leader
alors je les prie et longtemps l'hiver
maintenant je conduis et je trouve que
les deux ont des avantages et des
inconvénients
je dirai pas ce que j'ai toujours eu la
phobie de glisser et tomber ça m'est
arrivé assez rarement je touche du bois
aux fourneaux et l'asie mais mais ça
fait toujours peur quoi parce qu'il faut
toujours se préparer psychologiquement
et physiquement à l'arrivée de l'hiver
arrive on vous avait conduit pendant des
années vous conduisez toujours au
travail
non je viens en métro maintenant donc je
suis aussi piétonne et c'est l'enfer
parce que autant ont des glaces les
routes autant ont des glaces peu les
trottoirs ou enfin c'est pas toujours
bien fait et c'est hyper dangereux et
justement jeudi matin venant au travail
j'ai rencontré une collègue
nous marchions sur le trottoir et elle
s'est cassé la figure nous arrive tous
de se casser la figure
d'ailleurs rien aux articles qu'on a
fait il ya une couple d'années ont
montré aux nouveaux arrivants comment
marcher comme des canards avancé sur la
glace c'est la technique vous marcher
comme ça il n'y a pas de danger on
glisse son essai d'un fait du patin en
fait non c'est un goy les canadiens
aussi de souche qui sont nés ici
bon c'est pas inné fois c'est qu'à sa
gueule on apprend au fur et à mesure
mais sérieusement les hôpitaux sont
chargés des cas dans les urgences
urgence comme ça les gens qui ce qu'ils
sont bien mal à l'hiver c'est le
principal problème du fait qu'on se
retrouve à l'urgence ici à montréal
notamment question tomtom canada ceci
nous permet de glisser vers notre
question tam-tam canada de quoi
s'agit-il leur a dit cette semaine
alors comment gérez-vous votre en sport
dans un climat difficile moi le coin de
questions quels sont vos trucs pour vous
transporter en sécurité par mauvais
temps
et bien là on a testé la faire nous même
ensemble vous avez convaincu ce matin
france matin mais l'autre jour de sortir
le matin comme ça faisait très froid qui
vont un peu j'aurais peut-être dû
regarder la météo et la température
avant de faire cette proposition
d'autant que je n'avais pas de gants
j'ai vu la vidéo j'ai vu on a souffert
ensemble ce que vous avez fait elle a
dit si elle dit stéphane il faut a pu me
faut faire un petit effort on tue en
contre l'hiver tu leur manque la route
l'hiver et elle a eu l'idée donc de
croquer ces images et on entasse est
difficile à écouter parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de vent et c'est même difficile
au regard des prix fixés non regarde ça
ensemble
c'est très bref ça complique les
transports ça complique la vie au canada
et on veut savoir cette semaine que vous
viviez ailleurs comment ça se passe
et puis ça fait une tempête de sable
comment ça se passe quels sont vos trucs
on passe à travers mes mauvais temps
nous
alors la question n'a pas gelé
l'imagination certains auditeurs
téléviseur un téléviseur des gens qui
nous écoutent sur l'internet comme ça on
ose y répondre et c'est bien c'est
fantastique
d'abord une réaction qui viennent de new
yorker a dit c'est skyler stevens qui
nous dit à new york où j'habite dans le
mauvais pardon à new york où j'habite
voilà quand le mauvais temps se lève la
ville et sur l'océan atlantique comme
vous le savez je prends le temps de
prendre le train et je mets ma voiture
au garage
une idée c'est une très bonne idée le
train n'est jamais incapacité par la
neige sauf quand les chutes déborde les
cinq ou six pouces donc une dizaine de
centimètres je crois dans votre pays le
canada
le problème du train ce n'est pas le
mauvais temps mais le souci de voir le
conducteur s'endormir aux commandes
aïe comme on l'a vu il y a deux ans a
bâti moi j'avoue que ça c'est embêtant
je préfère être maître de mon auto que
de me laisser conduire par un endormi un
drogué ou un débris mais vivent l'auto
automatique dans quelques années
j'entendais à la radio je sais pas si
c'était du section vrai j'ai tenté de
vérifier la ferme c'est ce qu'on entend
la radio se porte dit l'animateur de la
nouille les risques d'accident au canada
c'est un accident par soixante mille
kilomètres en moyenne avec l'automatique
on estime que ce sera un accident à tous
les 6 millions de kilomètres
wow qu'il y aurait je pense que
l'argument de solutions automatiques
donc pas une auto manuel mais
automatique ou une auto les cadeaux
qu'ils vont te nomme tout expliquer
c'est que ce n'est pas encore très
répandu alors dans ce pays a pas
vraiment de taux encore autonomie
automatique au cameroun l'auditeur
jiovani bengono écrit la chose suivante
en arrivant vous lisez alors il dit
c'est la gabégie total donc nous allons
nous avons vérifié le mot c'est la
gestion financière un peu chaotique car
exact dans le monde du transport images
et vous que nous avons ici qu'est ce
qu'il veut du mage imaginez vous les
jeunes et vous bien sûr certains
villages nature jean bancaire ce matin
donc c'est la gabégie total dans le
monde du transport imaginez vous que
nous avons ici
les taxis prennent six places et il n'y
a presque pas de transports en commun
bref c'est comme ça ici et nous sommes
habitués alors c'est des taxis
collectifs 1 christian tremblay au
québec dit oui c'est vrai trop de
conducteurs ne pense pas autrui par
exemple en hiver combien de fois on voit
des véhicules devaient usd en anglais
mais curieusement devons utilitaire
sport
qui roule dépassant la limite de vitesse
permise se croyant en sécurité un oui le
débat quand la glace il a sa main ce
prix du monde et ils peuvent pas arrêter
s'il vous plaît faites attention aux
autres pays que vous n'êtes pas le seul
sur les routes
merci oui merci à conduite hivernale 101
pour nouveaux arrivants un reportage une
entrevue avait réalisé il ya un an et
trois mois environ à radio canada
international à marivan et c'est avec un
expert qui est consulté au niveau du
continent
oui bien sûr parce que il le connaît il
connaît la réalité et il enseigne un peu
partout et je vous avoue qu'après la
semaine que nous avons passé j'ai bien
envie d'aller suivre son cours parce
qu'on est de passer du chaud au froid
aux mains de la pluie de la glace
verglas se déplacer en est on ne vécut
tout même j'ai vu de la brume alors
brouillard mais alors on est prêt pour
cette entrevue
extraits d'entrevues parce que bien sûr
nous on dépose sur notre page de top en
team canada
on vous propose quelque chose vous
pouvez ensuite poursuivre votre
découverte avec l'article au complet et
l'entrevue au complet voici un court
extrait avec carte dernier ou plutôt
carl nadeau experts non américains en
conduite hivernale pour michelin les
conditions sont hyper spéciales et qu'on
ne rencontre pas nécessairement dans
d'autres pays parce que souvent on
essaie de trouver des exemples où est ce
que les gens peuvent se rattacher
quelque chose qui commercent oui mais
malheureusement d'amagne la glace si
vous venez d'être du sud de la france ou
de paix pour tous dans le monde du nord
afrique ou ailleurs vous en ayez pas vu
beaucoup de neige et de glace
on essaie donc cesser ces défis d'imagés
sommet à la base c'est excessivement
glissant le tout le monde déjà glissé ce
rêve sur le savon dans d'autres bêtes
c'est un peu comme ça que nos routes
vont voir leur pour pour l'hiver
heureusement maintenant au québec une
loi qui oblige d'avoir des pneus adaptés
les conditions et si vous êtes des
nouveaux arrivants de les voir
rapidement que les sandales je l ai
trouvé que c'est un peu froid pour
l'hiver donc ça va être la même chose
pour votre véhicule on a besoin
d'adapter de mettre des pneus devant
mais dites-vous que jour au lendemain
tout vaut changer
youpi c'est vraiment un trait qui passe
hélas faut vraiment changer complètement
sa conduite
à la base le meilleur conseil qu'on peut
donner c'est d'adapter sa vitesse
alors bien sûr la suite sur tarn canada
soudain de nos hyperliens un rappel ici
au niveau international les 10 à 24 ans
principales causes de décès ce sont les
accidents de la route est un des pays où
les plus sécuritaires au monde
en autos et puis ça s'améliore d'année
en année les statistiques les plus
récentes 91 3228 personnes sont décédées
sur nos routes et 170 mille blessés en
2010 deux mille personnes sont décédées
et 123 blessés
et ça alors que le nombre de véhicules
automobiles a augmenté d'environ 60 à
70%
il est donc la recette magique du canada
la ceinture de sécurité
les coussins gonflables c'est 10 à 24
ans il ya des des passagers et il ya des
conducteurs alors les jeunes qui
commencent à conduire mais aussi des
passagers exactement
alors ça c'est ses aïeux je me rappelle
avoir fait des entrevues avec des zones
easter en afrique
concernant les dangers noma en taxi par
exemple le fait que des fois dandy dans
des villages c'est pendant cette aube et
néons canon je me souviens plus un
auteur qui faisait ses cartes ya
quelqu'un ici qui tue quelqu'un sur la
route dans le village ou dans la ville
les policiers peuvent rien faire pour
sauver la vie du de celui qui a causé
l'accident
les gens l'accusent tout de suite et
veulent dénicher des drôles de
situations le jeu quand même ils ont pas
d'hiver mais ils ont d'autres problèmes
ceci nous amène à notre vidéo vidéo
virale je vous dis il ya eu aucun blessé
grave dans cette histoire peut-être
quelques blessés légers heureusement mes
100 véhicules qui se sont tamponnés sur
le taux de 401 la principale autoroute
canadienne dans le corridor toronto
montréal dans a pas loin de toronto
c'était mardi matin ou samedi dernier je
me souviens plus oui c'est récent ses
récents ses récents première vidéo
virale de l'année 2010 est au canada et
on va regarder ça ensemble
les deux
je voulais
ergo
[Musique]
c'était annoncé ça roulait trop vite
c'est ça dont canada faut faire bien
attention mais ce matin j'ai il ya vu ce
tableau s'était dégagée dans mon secteur
50 kilomètres plus loin c'était le bilan
à huy la définition officielle du
byzance et trois heures devant à 100 km
heure je pense mais là c'était bizarre
au centre-ville de montréal ce matin
elsa restantes année une autre lettre b
hunter des gens qui nous écrit ou
gilbert talbot j'imagine qu'il est au
québec il dit la chose suivante
qu'est-ce qu'il dit anne-marie bon alors
il fuit la neige et le vin sont les
seuls coupables de cet accident pour 1
interrogations je n'y crois pas un ou
deux conducteurs avec un joint donc un
joint hier peuvent facilement faire
partie de ce genre d'accident nos
premiers ministres ne l'admettront pas
et n'oseront pas en parler c'est sûr et
certain
mais nous nous en perdons dans nos
articles des dangers de l'automobile et
du volant et de la cannabis bientôt les
peut-être légal au canada niveau de la
consommation françois rochon radis écrit
la chose suivante ou toujours par
rapport aux à la question de vitesse et
d'accidents il dit ce n'est pas la
vitesse qui me fait peur sur nos
autoroutes à 110 ou 115 kilomètres-heure
ça me semble tout à fait raisonnable ce
qui me fait peur c'est les chaudrons les
camions avec leurs palettes en arrière
qu'ils y donne dit il de gauche à droite
là l'expression et et finissent par
dépasser sur l'accotement
les hommes d'affaires en chemise blanche
cravate cellulaire à l'oreille et
papiers de contrats sur le volant devant
eux les deux mains sur le volant avec
une distance raisonnable du président du
précédent y apportant à rien de plus
simple
mais heureusement on avait une tumeur au
canada nous arrêtent et lorsqu'on a on
sait pas ce qu'on fait et par rapport à
cette question des pneus d'hiver au
québec c'est obligatoire depuis quelques
années oui c'est la seule province au
canada on impose sa et récemment je
pense que c'est il ya deux mois même pas
deux mois l'ontario a dit non on
n'imposera pas les enquêtes nous
démontre que ça ne
ça fonctionne un arrêt du pote ça ne
vaut pas la dépense autrement dit c'est
tout un chacun peut être que les
québécois devraient s'intéresser
davantage à cette nouvelle cession des
neiges mieux en ontario moi je ferai pas
de commentaire c'est curieux peut-être
parce que j'habite au québec je n'arrive
pas à imaginer de conduire l'hiver sans
l'univers ouais enfin je me dis que ce
serait je sais pas ça ça fait seul je
n'oserais pas être la première à dire
tiens je vais faire un hiver sans
réponse dans l'ouest canadien moi j'ai
conduit pendant des années sans nous
d'hiver parce qu a pas de neige l'hiver
pratiquement à la celanese sèche
ici c'est mouillé et puis c'est toujours
entre le point de congélation et millet
-25 ça bouge beaucoup l'avocat alors que
la belle ibère est plus stable
on est on est pas des experts de la
conduite automobile
en hiver nous pouvons en été il ya des
gens qui sont des experts sur les routes
de glace du canada
ce réseau qui existe de façon éphémère
trois quatre mois par année même pas
quatre mois trois mois de la fin janvier
ou à la mi mars
et cela compte on peut ravitailler dj
village autochtone oui tu grand nord
canadien du mans mais ce qu'ils ont des
pneus cloutés pour ce premier sur cette
room de glace je pense qu'on devrait
avoir aussi des pneus d'hiver n'est pas
moi oui et on va demander l'air va les
voir on va aller à la source première
vue une des premières vidéos jamais
réalisée par radio canada est en
national je pense qu'on remonte loin à
trois ou quatre ans et c'est un de nos
collègues laval qui est de la section
anglaise de radio canada qui a produit
du canada international qui a produit ça
on a un court extrait bien sûr la vidéo
complète sur le site web de santé canada
pour le moment voici un avant-goût de la
réalité des autoroutes de glace et des
camionneurs dans le grand nord canadien
[Musique]
jusqu à mon goût
m
que
n at some point aux puncheurs inc
de mes couilles
bon
[Musique]
on
jack et tony fait que l'homme d'origine
à gonaté
les associations
[Musique]
l'équipe
icefrog nombre qui n'a pas de risque
[Musique]
encore une fois l'idée c'est de ne pas
aller trop rapidement
ça ne diminuer la vitesse en hiver au
canada mais l'été est ce qu'on ne
devraient pas rouler comme sur certaines
autoroutes anonman y l'écran d'autoroute
fabriqués par le german jennings 130
km/heure et plus même sans limite
moi j'ai vécu en allemagne et c'était
vitesse illimitée
avez vous peur non j'avais un problème
c'est que j'avais le pied un peu lourd
j'avoue que ça a été fort agréable bien
jouer y avoir des gens qui exagèrent moi
je me dis tout net que les limites et
souris sera en place pour les gens qui
vont juste aller je vais vous dire je
roulais à deux entre 180 et 200 km/heure
et je me faisais dépassé à grande
vitesse voilà c'est ça c'est en fait
c'est pour les gens comme anne-marie non
mais tu sais pas si on conduit bien
c'est bien mais à des droits spécifiques
pour ça il n'y a pas que c'est vrai de
ces les mêmes dangers de nos autoroutes
oui mais c'est un fait c'est pdci ne
vous avait pas remarqué que souvent les
gens qui vont très vite vont également
beaucoup slalomer c'est à dire que c'est
rare qu'ils restent sur leur voix ils
vont jamais content
ils vont aller voyez moi c'est ça mais
j'avoue qu'en allemagne ils peuvent pas
le faire parce qu'il ya des gens qui
roulent à 100 km heure sur la voie de
droite dont quand arrive derrière à 180
ou 200 t'as intérêt à dégager rapidement
donc souvent on reste sur la voie rapide
mais là c'est la route qui est important
c'est il faut ça prend une bonne route
oui je m'excuse mais quand il ya des
bosses dans la route moi j'en ai vu des
rothschild sa province le change
effectivement
et puis ici si ça prend une bonne auto
aussi j'ai circulé entre edmonton et
calgary ya de 115 à 165 km heure et la
personne à côté de moi me disait monnaie
peux-tu ralentir je regarde en 65 jeu
mais je pensais que je roulais à 120
maximum par trop pour plus sans jamais
fait ça m'évite c'est parce que le taux
était une très belle auto sport et la
route était bien droites cet été et
serons plus là vous les conditions
intérim aurait pu écoper d'un sacré j'ai
roulé à 190km la bonne moto mais
d'accompagner la mare hier au quai à la
route il fait comme ça certes ce voyage
ya qu une seule ligne à la on savait
qu'il y en avait 51km droit pour un
poids plume il ya même c'est et ça
c'était dans ce pays
alors je vais vous dire un truc j'étais
la seule dans la légalité
vous étiez tous les deux en inégalée
voilà système allemand permis exact je
suis rassuré on a une on a fait une
entrevue et qu'un autre star aux
etats-unis dans l'état de virginie qui
nous posent des questions sur les
nouvelles limites de vitesse au canada
parce que des ajustements si on roule
pas à la même vitesse partout au pays et
avait des provinces où on peut se
permettre de leur allouer ou les plus
lents rapidement notamment dans les
rocheuses canadiennes
si ça vous intéresse on a sur notre page
web
un reportage ou une entrevue qui
s'appelle quelles sont ces nouvelles
limites de vitesse sur les routes au
canada vous cliquez vous pouvez regarder
il n'y a pas de vidéo il ya du sang mais
c'est quand même pas trop mal et puis
maintenant la vidéo
je vais proposer notre webmaster les
directement à cette question envoyé par
une c'est un appel téléphonique d'une
idriss qui nous a appelés dans les
derniers jours ya peut-être même pas une
semaine
parce que vous savez que pour rentrer en
contact avec nous vous pouvez nous
écrire sur facebook vous pouvez nous
écrire adresses français à robert ctrc
in est pressé annonce pas ça qu'est ce
que c'est oui c'est ça oui français @
rcnm travaux stéphane adam et moi ou
encore vous pouvez utiliser numéro de
téléphone qui connaît ce rappel de notre
numéro de téléphone qui peut le lire
aussi sur l'appareil
seules les personnes plus jeunes mais
lui donnons pas besoin d'une aide
peuvent le faire
oui on vous rembourse vos gars 5 à 4 5 9
7 70 94 09 4 voici cette auditrice qui a
composé numéro pour nous poser la
question suivante au nom et madame
nathalie gauthier m'a rappelé aux 54 9
0c concernant les contraventions par
cadres photos que j'ai vues sur le pont
de l'île-aux-tourtes de savoir si je
peux les contester et ou six états va ça
va être par un recours collectif
alors j'aimerais avoir un peu plus de
détails à ce sujet alors j'aimerais que
vous me rappelez lui merci en bois alors
là
pour répondre à cette question quoi
faire avec vos contraventions de radars
photo au québec il ya des bonnes choses
que vous puissiez que maintenant
contester le gouvernement québécois a
décidé qu'il n'allait pas pour le moment
contester une décision d'un juge le mois
dernier il ya un peu plus d'un mois
maintenant
qui disait que puisqu'il ya pas vraiment
policiers derrière ces appareils de
capture de la votre plaque
d'immatriculation comment il n'y a pas
de preuves humaine que l'équipement
était bien calibrée donc vous pouvez
contester
et là je vous dis toutes les nouvelles
contraventions présentement sont mis de
côté ces deux nouvelles la semaine
dernière gouvernement mais ça de côté
on sait plus trop quoi faire avec ça
alors que ça existe dans d'autres
provinces ne sais pas si ce jugement là
va faire boule de neige à travers tout
le pays montrent que c'est intéressant
mais c'est l'avenir sans les machines
qui décident de notre culpabilité sans
intervention du juge
c'est ça l'avenir on est coupable avant
même de partir le matin vers le travail
mais c'est que le radar a capté la
vitesse oui de la personne comme il y a
une règle qui dit que par exemple la
vitesse et pas plus de 220 km le radar
perçoit une veste et une vitesse de
centimes mais c'est elle prend une photo
viennent il ya un problème j'ai eu une
fois c'était dans une endroit des
temples ja rule est à 51 km là alors
c'est plus que permis et ruia puis
messieurs les policiers il m'a fait
stopper lé auto beam montrer puis 17 56
pis moi j'avais les régulateurs de
vitesse plus pas plus de 50 ha oui j'ai
dit écoutez si vous voulez contesté là
puis c'est la voie de la loi contre moi
un gars qui conduit normalement je sais
pas si la machine ça fonctionnait mal
aux kouao lui il avait quelque chose
antalya dans sa machine vous avez raison
il ya en alberta iressa main et avait
une machine comme ça qui fonctionnait
pas bien c'était une personne qui la
tenait oui et on a découvert la sphère
et toutes les contraventions émises
depuis au delà d'un an est annulé parce
qu'il ya des gens qui ont aimé ça pas
d'alluré au jour le jour n'est pas cinq
anglais à 30 ans à vue au monde marque à
51,7 systématique or donc moi j'ai
plutôt l'impression que les
contraventions qu'il faut contester
c'est celle qui sont devenus des humains
concrètement c'est un peu comme ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure au sujet des
voitures autonomes mais seulement celles
des voitures autonomes qui vont réduire
les accidents aa par 6 millions de
kilomètres
parce que finalement ben la machine est
la règle et elle applique
oui mais le policier des jeux d'hier
quand ils arrêtent une personne à 50 km
heure sur une zone de 30 il y en a deux
autres qui sont passés puis les deux
autres qui ont la chance là tant mieux
pour toi qui était en vérité à 51 au
lieu de 56 étaient au dessus dans tout
ça j'ai pas discuter mais c'est que je
discutais c'est que la machine il marqué
56 à 51
je sais que j'ai roulé bah en fait ya un
problème quand j'ai passé mon test de
conduire à le métier m'a dit c'est une
route de 50 pourquoi vous allez à 50
parce que c'est la loi non mais ici au
québec tout le monde vous le 15 km plus
au large
ok mais est ce que vous êtes en train
d'aimer je me dis que je peux aller plus
vite mais c'est à vous alors quel est
son nom je me rappelle pas faut
absolument le yacht est écouté bref 30
secondes
si la semaine prochaine on parlait de
votre sport d'hiver favori que vous
soyez ici au canada ou en afrique ce
serait quoi votre sport de divers
favoris ou c'est quoi ce que ce sera un
sujet intéressant on glisse vers quelque
chose qui nous intéresse pas vous voulez
autre chose comme question de tam-tam
moi puisque je travaille pour espace
autochtone j'aimerais parler des
raquettes des bonniches ah bon oui c'est
un fait divers la raquette faire de la
raquette de l'espionnage un trottoir mon
préféré c'est éviter l'hiver de toutes
mes forces
donc voila mais je trouve que c'est
quand même un sujet intéressant parce
que ça peut nous permettre à nous les
gens du sud
exilé ici de découvrir quelque chose
j'ai fait de se lancer et j'aurai un
sujet pour vous que j'avais fait
justement là-dessus à rci sait
apprivoiser l'hiver à travers des sports
d'hiver abandon aller faire du ski de
fond aller faire du patin les faire de
la raquette aller faire du ski alpin
commandes n'ont pas votre mission à
votre émission à votre espace autochtone
semaine vous parle en fait je vais vous
parler d'un reportage qui a fait mon
collègue guy bois parce qu'on part jouer
au bingo dans une réserve autochtone
près de sept îles à oicha tu manioc tena
mme et elle a réussi du premier coup
la cwa chatte mak mani utenam
donc c'était malioténam autrefois près
de 7 sins ça veut dire quelque chose
comme rivière du loup a coûté la vous
poser trop de questions
j'aurais peut-être une réponse pour vous
les jeunes laissez-moi voir mais c'est
hyper intéressant ce reportage là a été
présenté au téléjournal donc à la
télévision ici au canada et on se
retrouve dans les salons des d'aider des
gens qui jouent au bingo parce que le
bingo est présenté à la radio
et ça fait vivre toute une communauté
alors allez découvrir ce reportage qui a
été donc télévisés et qui est aussi sur
la page des espaces au total est ce que
vous êtes capable de lever la main
jusqu'ici sans faire votre hitler là
vous aussi ou si vous avez des questions
vous aura dit anne-marie vont piocher
meinau et stéphane nous disent au revoir